the Joe Rogan experience testosterone
makes you do really stupid [ __ ] well
they're all competing against each other
and they're trying to out macho each
other I mean you could go there's a
bunch of Twitter accounts you can go and
see what's that one hold this beer yeah
there's a Twitter account called hold my
beer well exactly why I do everything
it's like roofs and no stupid [ __ ] it's
almost all men there's occasionally a
drunk girl doing something stupid but
it's almost entirely men so I would
think that men trying to out macho men
are somewhat inferior then because they
do a lot of dumb stuff maybe their
hormones are not in balance like ours
they definitely when competing against
each other will do dumb [ __ ] yeah das
drones to blame well they try to out
macho each other yeah yeah I mean some
don't some are smart and they don't but
you know there's it's just a part of
being a man it's like trying to prove
that you're not scared what else is part
of being a man tell me about men what do
you wanna know know what else is what
else is uh very manly that women don't
understand what what what what what
don't women understand about men that's
a good question I have no idea what you
understand about us hmm maybe just speak
from experience mm-hmm yeah but I don't
know what like if we ask a guy like
what's wrong Oh see that's nonsense talk
like honey what's wrong what's wrong and
you're like nothing sometimes art really
is it really nothing yeah sometimes you
just wanted to like decompress okay you
know sometimes just was that annoying
when a girl does that depends on the
girl you know depends the girl she's
annoying yeah it's annoying but if
you're in love with her and she's
awesome 100 percent that's a hundred
percent yeah if someone's asking you
questions and you're getting really
[ __ ] annoyed it's probably not the
question it's probably more the person
if you think someone's amazing and they
ask you something stupid you'll just
laugh you won't get it
and you guys could both joke around
about how stupid it was how the question
was dumb that's good you get angry its
most likely you're just like annoyed
anyway so you're just like ready - ready
- ready to sort of fall over that
annoying and - get out get out of my
space kind of attitude because you're
already annoyed with them anyway you
already don't really like them yeah
there's probably something that's
already rubbing you the wrong way and
you're tolerating each other instead of
enjoying each other hmm yeah I mean I
would imagine a person like you a very
intense person you probably have a
difficult time finding you know like if
you get a square peg in a square hole
and everything slides in together
perfect and everything's amazing
personality wise you know behavior wise
mm-hmm I would imagine with something
like you look it's very particular you
have to find someone who appreciates
your intensity right yeah like a lot of
times guys are they want a demure you
know sort of like docile little creature
well summers on the table in here when
you get back right and while you're out
there with a [ __ ] go-kart going 150
miles an hour in the driveway
yeah you're going to yeah so if you're
saying what's wrong the guys are [ __ ]
nothing it's probably a bunch of the
[ __ ] that's really wrong it's very
insightful
yeah all right so what what don't men
understand about women um she's tapping
her fingers everything I mean I just
think that we'd like to be you know we
like to be told what you're thinking hmm
I do I'd like to know what someone's
thinking you know the whole like we're
just you know I'm just keeping to myself
like tell me about it now I want to know
what yourself is thinking about I want
to know about you what's going through
your head like communication now is this
universal amongst all your girlfriends
when you get together and talk about I
would think so yeah yeah so the problem
is like you look at a guy and say you
know you really like this guy you know
like this [ __ ] dude some
raising mystery like what's going on
your headband yeah that's not good spit
it out
everyone wants to know where they stand
and what someone's thinking oh where
they stand well because and it's more
they stand on what they're thinking
because you know what if the thing about
someone else oh so you need to know yeah
you know if you're all-in yeah 100% yeah
I'm just an all-in person so for me it's
not a mystery like you won't know what's
going on my head I'll tell you right now
that's intense yeah yeah so yeah for
guys like off drifting you automatically
assumed this [ __ ] thinking
wrong somebody else now what are you up
to yeah I guess guys probably do that
too and girls I hear nice things to
girls like to hear you know girls like
to be you know girls like of course you
know to be appreciated just like a guy
does I mean I think that's my advice
most of the time in relationships I'm
like sympathy goes a really long way
because I know it goes a long way with
me no matter what facet of my life it is
but you know sympathy goes a long way so
you know if your husband's in a bad mood
then why don't you just actually start
off with instead of feeling like you're
underappreciated going hey baby you look
like you've had a really long day and
I'm sure you've been working your butt
off like what can I can I make you
dinner like what do you want what's your
favorite you know and they'll probably
go oh you know what is not that not that
big of a deal you know what babe I'm
fine hey let me take you out to dinner I
get to eat the sympathy gets sympathy
back and you don't it's not it's not
good to do it to get it necessarily but
you should really feel like you are
sympathetic like if they're in a bad
place try and help them that's sound
advice yeah nice to each other just
sympathy just be nice because most
people go under appreciate especially in
a relationship I think the longer it
goes there's a lot of under appreciation
and assumptions that get made about who
does what and checks that box off and
yeah and people do especially kids right
amounts true with kids it gets way worse
it's just there's a lot of time that's
involved with taking care of those
little suckers you got to pay attention
to them and talk to them and they and if
you have more than one like once you
start talking to one the other one wants
to just chime in you know and show you
what they're doing and wait I was busy
just trying to make sure you don't die
and now I got a deal with this yeah
yeah I think people get used to things
you know and that's that's part of the
problem they get used to each other for
granted yeah they do and then and then
you know it's like I always tell people
aspire to be the person you pretend to
be when you're trying to get laid if you
could be that person all the time you
would have a much better life if you
just like I also love the expression for
every hot chick there's a dude sickest
crooner yeah I don't say it that way but
yes I use more flavorful language but
yeah is that was that too much or too
little too little oh yeah how would you
say it for every hot chick there's a guy
somewhere that's tired of [ __ ] her
okay okay but yeah I mean I guess but
that's not entirely true either
no I mean it's for the most part a lot
of the times it's true but a lot of the
times people don't appreciate your
sentiment exactly and then it's with
various aspects of your life like I
always feel like that like I just got
over the flu a week and a half ago I had
the flu and I was sick for like two days
and then when I was sick I was thinking
man I don't appreciate how good I feel
when I'm healthy hmm because Here I am
lying here I'll akin watching Netflix
feeling like [ __ ] going Wow well I'm
healthy and I'm working out and I'm
running and doing jujitsu and all the
activities and I got all this energy and
I feel great like I just can't do
anything right now I just take it for
granted you do yeah get like you know
feel the joy of just being healthy it
just escapes us we just so think it's
normal
yep
[Applause]